hi everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Nana dagnitzi who just won her game
congratulations Nana a very nice game
today how do you feel being back at the
Karen's cup and in the US in San Luis
yeah I really love this place and
whenever I get the invitation I mean I
always
feel
very happy
so yeah this is my third time and so far
I think it's everything is good so I
hope to continue like this I know you've
played a lot of tournaments before
coming here I was I was watching the
broadcast earlier
how do you train for these tournaments
how do you
stay in shape like work on chess and do
you have time to analyze your games in
between the tournaments or do you
analyze after yeah actually it's not not
that easy because I played very
important tournament like Grand prix's
last step because this tournament and
before that I played Armageddon in in
Berlin yes yeah and yeah yeah you really
need Le and energy but yes and I'm I'm
trying I'm trying to
stay focused and show my best I mean I
don't have a choice because all these
tournaments can I play I love this
tournament so I cannot say no to I say
is your family supportive of your
travels my family is very supportive
otherwise it wouldn't be possible
I have two kids so
that is great to hear last question I
don't want to keep you I want you to
have enough time to rest for tomorrow
you're probably still jet lagged from
Europe people wanted to find out on
Instagram about what is a like a meal
the kind of meal that you eat during
tournaments or what what kind of things
you enjoy to eat that give you the
energy either as you're playing or
during a tournament things that you
enjoy to eat if possible
so we have our choice here during the
game so
[Music]
um
which is great and some sweets okay all
right thank you so much nana I wish you
good luck in the next rounds and we'll
see you again soon